[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 2 mars voici
les titres
la fin d'une belle aventure le
football-club de versailles est éliminé
de la coupe de france défaite hier 2 à 0
contre nice en demi-finale pas de finale
au stade de france donc mais un parcours
historique accompli retour sur la
rencontre l'équipe amateur n'a pas
démérité et derrière les leurs les
supporters ont été au rendez vous près
de 80 ont fait le déplacement à nice
pour soutenir le fcv 78 à l'alliance
riviera est depuis versailles aussi les
yvelinois ont suivi la rencontre dans
les bars de la cité royale et puis large
page consacrée également la guerre en
ukraine 1 million de personnes ont été
déplacées dans le pays depuis l'invasion
russe environ 680 mille ont quitté le
territoire dans les yvelines l'état et
les collectivités se mobilisent pour les
accueillir nous avons pu recueillir les
témoignages de jeunes ukrainiens aidés
par le conseil départemental
mais avant de développer ses titres
c'est avec tristesse que nous avons
appris il ya quelques minutes la
disparition à 71 ans du journaliste jean
pierre pernaut élu l'année dernière
présentateur préféré des français il a
été la voix du journal de 13h de tf1
pendant 33 ans de 1988 à 2000 vingt
trois ans après avoir vaincu un premier
cancer de la prostate il est décédé des
suites d'un cancer des poumons
diagnostiqués en 2021 habitant à
louveciennes dans les yvelines nous
l'avions rencontré en novembre dernier à
l'occasion de la promotion de son livre
trente trois ans avec vous nos pensées
se dirigent bien évidemment vers sa
famille et ses proches
[Musique]
et avec moi pour le début de cette
édition quelque peu chamboulé michael et
demi d'euros bonsoir journaliste sport
de la rédaction de tv soit 118 on le
disait dans les titres fin de parcours
pour le fc versailles qui sort la tête
haute de cette coupe de france de
football les hommes de youssef chebbi
ont été battus 2 à 0 hier mardi par
l'ogcnice et est au stade des
demi-finales à l'alliance rivera on va
revenir avec vous sur la rencontre que
faut-il retenir alors le match s'est
déroulé en deux temps dès gorée en
première période les trois divisions à
des cars ne se font pas vraiment
ressentir les versailles et contiennent
bien les assauts des joueurs de la côte
d'azur malgré quelques frayeurs le
gardien dan delaunay garde ses cages
inviolées versailles se procure même une
demi occasion avec ce ballon chipé par
inzaghi race ou bas au niveau du milieu
de terrain mais le joueur est rattrapé
par les défenseurs niçois et diego
michel n'arrive pas à cadrer le score à
la pause 0 à 0 degré vers ses solides en
première mi-temps et en deuxième période
les versaillais crack versailles crack
rapidement peut-être trop rapidement le
joueur en forme du moment hamid gouri
profite d'une petite faute de marquage
sur 60 pour ouvrir le score sur cette
belle frappe dans la lucarne qui ne
laisse aucune chance au gardien
versailles et on joue la 48e minute
versailles tente de réagir mais sur sur
cet exploit personnel damine gouery
encore lui nice va doubler la mise avec
ce but de dole berg à la 73e minute
comme on dit dans le jargon la messe est
dite pourtant les versaillais ne se
démobilise pas il y aura quelques
situations comme sur ce centre avec
c'était de christopher iba y y mais la
tête de l'attaquant n'est pas assez
forte les niçois auront l'occasion de
mettre le troisième but mais la barre
sauve le gardien de la cité royale 2 à 0
ce sera le score final versailles n'est
absolument pas à rougir de sa
performance dans cette rencontre je n'ai
qu'une chose à leur dire rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour aller cette fois
ci en finale merci michael et et avant
cela la saison n'est pas finie les
versaillais pourrait connaître d'autres
émotions avec une montée en national ils
sont pour le moment leaders de leur
poule de nationale 2 et ce serait un
rêve également rejoint pour c'est vers
ça y est on va revenir justement sur la
rencontre avec nos deux invités alors
l'un est déjà connecté l'autre va
peut-être nous rejoindre en tout cas
avec nous il ya déjà jean-pierre me
bonsoir jean pierre moriau mange pas
avec nous en visioconférence président
du district de football est des yvelines
et vous aviez fait le déplacement à nice
pour assister à leur encontre premier
sentiment au lendemain de cette
élimination de versailles est ce que
vous êtes plutôt déçu au contraire fiers
du parcours accompli par par les
versaillais bien un peu les bleus un peu
déçu du résultat encore que il ya
plusieurs digues avaient plusieurs
divisions d'écart et et le résultat
finalement il est logique est par contre
un vrai un vrai sentiment de fierté
parce que ce qu'a fait ce qu'a fait le
snrc à 60,18 c'est exceptionnel je sais
c'est historique j'ai pas de
qualificatifs pour leur dire ô combien
nous sommes fiers de ce que l'europe là
bas on a le sentiment que versailles
tout de même et ça a été dit par nickel
dans le point qui vient de suivre à a
fait son match et finalement le match
s'est joué sur des détails
il ya eu une première très bonne
carrière des versaillais et finalement
ils craquent au retour des vestiaires
c'est les détails qui ont joué dans
cette rencontre il ya eu il y avait un
écart de niveau on le rappelle un
nationale 2 pour versailles trois
divisions d'écart avec l'ogcnice qui est
troisième de ligue 1
oui tout à fait vous savez c'est
toujours peur des détails que tout comme
console un seul ou moi est ce que
j'observe c'est que il y avait des gens
qui pensaient que le troisième de la
ligue 1 ne ferait qu'une bouchée d'un
club de nationale 2 c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé moi je peux vous dire que
dans les tribunes les régions qui
étaient les niçois qui étaient autour de
moi se disait bas il ya une très belle
équipe en face on va réussir à gagner ce
match et c'est et puis à la fin il était
bien content et soulagé d'avoir gagné et
il était bien content je le répète vous
étiez dans les tribunes où vous l'avez
dit l'ambiance est et était bonne à
l'alliance rivieras de nice il y avait
80 supporters on aura tout à l'heure
l'occasion de discuter avec le président
de l'association au football club de
versailles quelle était l'ambiance dans
les tribunes réservées tribune
c'était une ambiance sympathique
mais je le répète les niçois la mi temps
ils n'étaient pas ils n'étaient pas
rassurés quand même c'était pas fait
d'avancé et à la fin il était très
content d'ailleurs l'entraîneur de nice
me christophe galtier il l'a dit il l'a
fait par deux sauts de sa joie de la
qualification mais aussi de son
soulagement il a ajouté que versailles
n'avait pas fait que défendre ça montre
bien que versailles a défendu crânement
sa chance et nous en sommes fiers et ça
met fin donc à une aventure
exceptionnelle neuf tours franchis
depuis le 4e tour auquel et les
versaillais et était rentré quel regard
vous portez justement sur ce parcours
tout à l'heure vous parliez dit
d'histoire ils ont marqué durablement
l'histoire du football yvelinois mais à
côté il faut se souvenir que c'est là
c'est la première fois depuis 2000 vingt
quinze clubs de ce niveau arrive en demi
finale de la coupe de france le dernier
s'est fait en 2020 se décaler qui lui
est allé en finale
je pense qu'on s'en souviendra
effectivement longtemps et ce qu'il faut
souhaiter maintenant c'est que
les versaillais puis se terminer leur
saison c'est leur saison elle est déjà
exceptionnelle mais elle va devenir
encore plus exceptionnel et historique
si ils continuent leur parcours
maintenant au championnat national 2
pour accéder au championnat national a
commencé
dès samedi effectivement chateaubriand
prochain déplacement pour les hommes de
youssef chebbi et cet objectif vous le
disiez montée en national pour le mans
ils sont leaders de nationale 2 avec
trois points d'avancé sur la réserve de
lorient qui ne peut pas monter on le
rappelle cinq points sur short qui est
le principal concurrent dans cette poule
de nationale 2 à avoir un représentant
des yvelines dans le troisième échelon
national forcément ça fait rêver ce
serait bon pour le football yvelinois
absolument absolument c'est très bien
pour le football yvelinois
j'ai déjà le présent de le dire nous
avons nous allons battre nous allons
battre cette année le record
du nombre de licenciés on va atteindre
probablement 43000 notre dernier record
il ya quelques années était de 41 milles
et c'est bon pour le football c'est bon
pour le sport c'est bon pour le district
des yvelines c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon pour nous quoi que ce soit bien
c'est bon pour le foot yvelines on le
rappelle sur lequel est implanté un le
centre technique national de
clairefontaine où les équipes de france
et section jeunes mais aussi l'équipe de
france ça vient régulièrement et
d'ailleurs le football-club de
versailles a pu profiter des
installations pour préparer ce match
cette demi finale face à nice merci il
s'enquiert meurillon d'avoir été avec
nous
mais je le rappelle président du
district des divines de vie à voir aussi
ma quand traoré avec nous défenseurs du
football-club de versailles 78 pour une
première réaction après cette
élimination visiblement il n'a pas pu
nous rejoindre nous essaierons de
collecter sa réaction et vous on nous la
partagerons dans les prochaines éditions
de tv 78 contrairement aux quarts de
finale cette fois ci malheureusement pas
d'écran géant sur la place du marché à
versailles les supporters qui n'ont pas
pu faire le déplacement se sont
reportées vers les bars et les pubs de
la ville célia gars de son go et justine
brasier ont pu suivre la rencontre au
barreau parisse regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
versailles face à nice un club de
nationale 2 face à un club de ligue 1 le
coup d'envoi a été donné à 21h ce mardi
1er mars elle les supporters yvelinois
ont suivi cette demi finale de coupe de
france de football de prix la première
mi temps elles sont accrochés jusqu'au
bout les 00 deuxième mi temps je pense
que la fatigue s'est accumulée
malheureusement bat la différence de
niveau s'est fait ressentir et on s'est
pris les deux buts mais bon on sort avec
les honneurs dans ce pub situé rue
colbert avait ça ils étaient près de 150
à être venus soutenir l'équipe locale
sohail elle est quand même pas mal de
monde à une belle ambiance c'est sûr que
c'est pas un mardi ordinaire comme
d'habitude donc
c'est toujours un gros plus les bars et
les pubs versailles est une alternative
pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu faire le
déplacement à nice ceux qui n'ont pas pu
suivre la rencontre deux chaises ou
encore pour ceux qui voulaient tout
simplement profiter de l'ambiance
versaillaise
on est derrière notre club donc c'est
l'internaute ville celle assez rare donc
c'était assez puissant ça fait super
plaisir il y avait une super ambiance en
bas bon on n'a pas gagné mais on a vibré
ce soir match sympa on a un bon moment
en tout cas je suis contente quand même
avant
ça aurait été cool que vers sagan le fc
versailles et le cinquième club de
nationale 2 accéder aux demi finales de
coupe de france de football un parcours
historique pour le club même s'il aurait
aimé voir un but tous s'accordent à
saluer cette performance inédite aussi
de leurs parents ils ont fait plaisir ce
soir ils sortent franchement ils ont
fait un bon match le ballon en vouloir
et à leur merci pour nous avoir fait
vivre
on perd 2-0 mais ils ont vraiment pas à
rougir je suis un peu triste mais
vraiment je suis plus fier parce que
ils ont fait le taff n'ont pas démérité
je pense qu'il peut être fier de ses
poules de voir que larissa y arriva
alès d'evra si le club versailles et
s'est incliné 2 0 face à nice certains
supporters ils croient déjà pour l'année
prochaine c'est encourageant en plus le
club monte en puissance donc on y croit
on se dit que m
chaque année c'est pas la première fois
il ya deux trois ans on est aussi monté
on a aussi bien
jouer en coupe de france j'espère que
les prochaines années croît en attendant
les supporters du fc versailles espère
voir le club de national de monter d'une
division en national
là les bars de versailles plein pour
suivre la rencontre près de 80
supporters ont aussi fait le déplacement
à lisser nous retrouvons sur place
anthony paiera bonjour anthony bonjour
président de l'association du football
club de versailles à l'heure où on
enregistre entretien 15h58 vous trouvez
à l'aéroport pour rentrer justement à la
ddt sur la ville de versailles alors au
lendemain de cette défaite justement de
de votre club contre l'ogcnice on le
rappelle troisième de ligue 1 c'est un
peu le le duel de david contre goliath
quel est le sentiment qui prédomine chez
vous êtes fier tout de même du parcours
accompli ce qu'il ya un petit peu de
déception lendemain de cette défaite
ce sont les deux mêlées en temps
les supporters président de
l'association et en voulant
effectivement toujours plus entre
guillemets et savoir qu'on voit là on
voulait quand même accéder à ce final
c'est effectivement un petit peu de
déception de ne pas aller au stade de
france et de pouvoir enfin jouer en ile
de france
maintenant c'est aussi beaucoup de
fierté puisque on a vu lors du match
quand même que les voilà les joueurs ont
tenu une bonne mi temps ou quand même
déjouer les plans des niçois ont lésé
bien les ont bien bloqués en termes de
système de jeu le système de jeu qui
avait été mis en place par l'entraîneur
youssef chimie a bien fonctionné pendant
tout tout c'est tenir mi temps et puis
on appris on a été un peu cueilli
dès le retour des vestiaires par ce but
de bouri sur la une
peut-être une petite faute de marquage
ce est pas mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont
réaccéléré beaucoup tout de suite à
l'entrée à la la rente à la sortie des
vestiaires en deuxième mi temps et ça a
coûté cher à l'équipe de versailles on a
vu quelques unes
de votre journée d'hier la journée des
supporters alice comment ça s'est passé
en tribune pour vous comment était
l'ambiance
l'ambiance était très bonne c'est vrai
que moi j'étais voilà du côté de la
tribune officielle et c'était j'avais en
face de moi le coq du roi les supporters
versailles et qui mettait une grosse
ambiance à avant le coup d'envoi et qui
on a vu beaucoup qu'on entende et bien
et c'est vrai que dès que les supports
dernier soit ont commencé à donner de la
voix
à les entendre mais je sais qu'ils ont
oeuvré tout au long du match que je sais
aussi que certains qui tapait sur les
tambours ont des ampoules aux mains
aujourd'hui donc voilà ils ont travaillé
et ils ont le vrai comme des fous et
voilà on est super fiers à la fois des
joueurs qui nous emmenait dans cette
nouvelle aventure et chiens aussi des
supporters et de toute l'organisation de
tous les gens qui ont aidé à cette
organisation
bruno orlando et beaucoup d'autres
pierres voilà qui qui sont très fiers
d'avoir participé d'avoir pu participer
à cette aventure et maintenant on va
tout faire pour accompagner les joueurs
et l'équipe première pour cette ce qu'on
espère être une montée en national quand
on assure la saison prochaine qui sera
l'objectif en parler dans un jeu temps
juste avant regarder un petit extrait
des supporters de versailles présent à
[Musique]
avec le chant des supporters de
versailles qui a été fait tiges pendant
cette compétition de la coupe de france
vous étiez une poignée de fidèles
anthony à suivre régulièrement pendant
toute cette édition de la coupe de
france ô au fil des tours l'équipe de
versailles c'était le cas à lumbres à
sarre union à toulouse à périgueux aussi
on avait la chance d'être venu avec vous
pour pour le quart de finale face à
bergerac c'est une belle aventure
humaine avant tout on a l'impression à
cette coupe de france que vous avez vécu
entre supporters oui c'est une super
aventure humaine beaucoup de cohésion
entre les supporters
bien aidé par le groupe de vétérans et
de l'équipe voilà de versailles et bien
aidé par les épouses aussi que beaucoup
des blues se sont révélés et mais
aujourd'hui un peu plus peut-être
qu'avant le football grâce à cette
épopée et une position aussi avec
l'équipe première voilà qui est venu le
remercier et remercier tous les
supporters hier soir
c'était
un beau moment de cohésion on espère
garder pour la saison qui vient et les
saisons à venir voilà qui va permettre
de fédérer qui a permis de fédérer
beaucoup de monde et on espère fédérer
s'est encore jusqu'à la fin de la saison
pour pouvoir fêter une montée la saison
prochaine d'un interphone la suite c'est
de continuer à être derrière cette
équipe vous l'avez dit est montée en
national qui joue le troisième échelon
française
bien sûr bien sûr nous on souhaite
effectivement
fortifiée cette cohésion qui est apparu
ce grâce à la coupe de france on
souhaite aussi pouvoir voilà soutenir
les joueurs sur le sur leur parcours en
championnat à venir sur la fin de saison
et pouvoir leur donner tout notre
soutien pour qu'ils puissent
sentir qu'on est derrière eux et qu'on a
envie qu'ils réussissent cette chan
championnat de la meilleure des façons
possibles merci anthony perrin d'avoir
été avec nous avec plaisir mais on
vautours versailles et ses présidents en
cours avec nous aussi c'est
c'était très agréable d'être avec vous
merci de nous avoir accueillis et bon
retour vers versailles après donc cette
élimination le rappelle le football-club
de versailles et illumine la coupe de
france après sa défaite en demi finale
contre l'ogcnice 2 à 0 voilà ce qu'on
pouvait vous dire à propos de cette
information et 18 mois en tout cas qui
sortent la tête haute de cette
compétition tant le parcours accompli
est exceptionnel historique même pour le
club amateur objectif désormais vous
l'avez compris aller chercher en fin de
saison une montée en national le
troisième échelon français
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également de la
politique jean michel blanquer air
sera-t-il candidat dans les yvelines le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
souhaiterait devenir député dans le
département l'information nous a été
confirmée par une source interne à la
république en marché relayées par
plusieurs médias et jean michel blanquer
air aurait jeté son dévolu sur la
troisième circonscription des yvelines
problème et non des moindres la députée
sortante lrm béatrice pire on serait
bien candidate à sa propre succession
elle avait été élue pour la première
fois en 2010 est dans cette
circonscription qui comprend les cantons
de la celle saint cloud le chesnay saint
nom la bretèche et la commune des clayes
sous bois cela fait 7 jours désormais
que la russie a envahi l'ukraine face au
déclenchement du conflit armé la
mobilisation de l'état et des
collectivités évinoise et lancé le
préfet a envoyé une lettre aux élus pour
anticiper l arrivée d'ukrainiens le
conseil départemental de son côté a déjà
pris en charge des jeunes ukrainiens et
plusieurs communes organisent des
collectes les détails dans ce reportage
de nicolas landry voilà la lettre
adressée par le préfet jean jacques brot
au maire des yvelines une demande de
recensement des offres d'hébergement
chaque commune a reçu ce tableau qui
devra être envoyée à la préfecture
objectif centraliser les propositions
d'accueil de famille ukrainienne fuyant
leur pays nous allons créer une
centralisation quelque chose pour ces
offres
d'hébergement de sorte qu'elle soit bien
connu identifié on les fera remonter au
niveau national et dès qu'il y aura des
arrivées on fera des appariements entre
le type de logement sa situation sera
pas que roxy mythe et avec un moyen de
transport etc et les besoins des
familles au cas par cas dans la mesure
du possible je recommande que ces
propositions de logement d'hébergement
soit accompagnée de propositions
d'accompagnement c'est très important
que on n'ajoute pas au déracinement à
l'exil à la crainte de la guerre et de
ses conséquences en plus une situation
d'isolement dans les yvelines en france
officiellement il n'ya pas encore
d'arriver dans les yvelines mais des
ukrainiens déjà présent en france au
moment du déclenchement de la guerre
sont accueillis au campus des mureaux
huit jeunes au total âgés de 16 à 39 ans
nous assurons à ces jeunes au gîte et le
couvert il va falloir aussi une aide
d'urgence pour qu'il puisse habiller son
parti pour quelques jours donc avec
quelques vêtements il va falloir aussi
la retrouver une activité
d activité alinéa triste parce qu'ils
n'ont rien
des activités tout court de la formation
en particulier d'information la mystique
il faut qu'ils apprennent le français
par ailleurs des commune yvelinoise se
mobilisent déjà en proposant des
collectes vêtements produits d'hygiène
ou encore literie des points de dons
sont mises en place notamment à poissy
aux mureaux ou encore à carrières sous
poissy
outre les aides matérielles un geste lui
symbolique pour l'ukraine on l'a vu dans
plusieurs communes de france et même sur
la tour eiffel c'était au tour de la
commune de carrières sous poissy de le
faire la façade de l'hôtel de ville et
éclairé en jaune et bleu depuis le mardi
1er mars couleurs du drapeau ukrainien
le même jour à saint germain en laye un
drapeau ukrainien a été hissé sur la
mairie aux côtés de ceux de la france et
de l'europe
depuis dimanche dernier donc huit jeunes
ukrainiens et ukrainienne âgé de 16 à 39
ans sont accueillis au campus des
mureaux en séjour en france au moment du
déclenchement de la guerre ils sont
restés ici avant d'être orientés dans
les yvelines ils sont logés et nourris
dans cette structure gérée par le
département céline charles et nicolas
landry sont allés les rencontrer
[Musique]
michine wright my songs and planes un
guitare piano créé leur
leader bill gates a
cédé à ben jawad
mais qui n'oublie dos
un acteur actrice ait played in des
filatures mike woodson myton maintenant
laisser series
is not take you because it rock and
building
[Musique]
l'ajout
de noms
mais by normalement mais li fei cette
cause
ividence youth reform mini
110 mm good as a way 6
blocks prêts
ma femme me in my town deux grandes
banques us
un des cinq mille photo ou une vidéo
wendy qui rêvent de disparue ce cas vie
[Musique]
peinture
bourgogne discours end à stand money for
my
family l'école week-end en
france
n'est pas acquis que
on distingue un
flop
industries d'haïti coeur me and 10
voilà pour la première partie de cet
entretien dont l'intégralité sera à
retrouver sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme et puis au delà des
collectivités d'autre élan de solidarité
notamment celui du cirque est nicolas
zavatta production douchez l'équipe se
dit prête à accueillir des artistes
ukrainiens pour son spectacle 2022 afin
de leur permettre de continuer à
travailler dans un premier temps le ciel
va accueillir les pelouses ukrainienne
de l'un de ses artistes vedettes il est
parti en urgence pour aller la chercher
propos recueillis par céline charles
de
la frontière et attendent pologne donc
lui ce qu'il a fait il est parti hier
matin et il est parti le rejoindre en
pologne pour la mettre en sécurité elle
et puis son fils quoi il m'a dit qu'il
n'était pas encore arrivé là bas mais
que tout se passait bien qu'elle ait été
déjà en sécurité en pologne que tout
s'était bien passé
pour pouvoir la récupérer on va essayer
de faire venir d'autres artistes qui
viennent de l'ukraine qui sont bloqués
eux dans l'europe qui devait qui
devaient rentrer chez eux mais à cause
des événements qui veulent pas rentrer
chez eux je les comprends donc on est en
train de voir certains sites français
centaines de voir pour les accueillir
qu'ils aillent de quoi se loger et
pourra vivre je suis dans ce que le
gouvernement va nous dire ce qu'on peut
accepter nous on est prêt à accueillir
des familles je suis ici on est déjà une
quarantaine mais on en a déjà tant
d'éloges non pas que personne si c'est
des artistes ont déjà torride en échec 6
et les personnes qui l'ont fait que de
la manutention pourrait bien monter le
voilà le chapiteau piché des
palefreniers ou des choses comme ça que
j'avais ya plein de métiers d'accor
mais le cir que nicolas zavatta
production douchez qui est installé à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines les spectacles se déroulent
jusqu'au 13 mars c'est la fin de ce
journal avant de vous laisser je vous
rappelle cette information que nous
avons appris juste avant de prendre
l'antenne la disparition a 71 ans et du
journaliste jean pierre pernaut élu
l'année dernière présentateur préféré
des français il a été la voix du journal
de 13h de tf1 pendant 33 ans de 1988 à
2000 vingt trois ans après avoir vaincu
un premier cancer de la prostate il est
décédé des suites d'un cancer des
poumons diagnostiqués en 2021 habitants
à louveciennes dans les yvelines et nous
l'avions rencontré en novembre dernier à
l'occasion de la promotion de son livre
33 ans avec vous dans un instant à la
suite des programmes sur tv 78 un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 société présentée
par mélanie poké le thème ce soir les
vacances sans quitter les yvelines belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]